you know I think what makes Innovative
companies Innovative is that is that
they recognize that they create
something it become everybody else is
the follower and now you have the
opportunity to create it again sort of
the innovator's Dilemma right which is
you're a Pioneer and you know you become
the generic you know you become the
kleenex or the Q-tip but eventually you
know when there's a Marketplace others
will do it and those Industries will
mature when JetBlue first showed up as
an airline they were the first airline
to make all of the seats on their planes
and in leather and put uh TVs in every
seat and I remember that was their
advertising for quite a while it's like
everyone gets a leather seat everyone
gets a TV and then it you know it turned
out to be a thing and it before too long
every Airline had all leather seats and
every Airline had seats on every plane
and yet I remember the advertising
JetBlue was still talking about how they
invented it nobody really cared anymore
because it was now generic great
companies especially the ones that
continue to innovate year over year
um they think of their companies less
like companies and think of themselves
more like social movements and so that
why becomes a filter our are we doing
this are we building upon this and
unfortunately success becomes a great
liability for a lot of organizations
where all of a sudden the thing that
inspired them and drove them in the
early days the thing that was the
foundation for all their Innovation gets
replaced by quarterly or annually annual
goals
you know short-term incentive structures
and unfortunately that Foundation that
very inspiring Foundation becomes
forgotten dare I say so it has to be a
filter for for decision making and a
rallying cry for people to try and
figure out how to advance